we can burn the end of the string don't
let your guitar on fire
living on the edge um don't breathe in
the chemicals um
hey guys
if you've ever picked up a classical
wizard i noticed that
the bass strings
the lower three wound with metal
if they sound a bit dull or they kind of
lost their brilliance
it's probably because it's time to
change them
sometimes you can also tell because they
look a bit
discolored
rusty
so i thought we could uh walk through
today
how to change the strings in a classical
guitar
okay so let's change these strings to do
this you're going to need a new pack of
strings
a peg winder you don't absolutely need
this but it speeds up the process and a
nail clippers or something to to cut the
strings the strings i'm using today are
aquala alabastro light tension strings
i'm a big fan of light tension strings
and these are actually nile gut trebles
it's a formula for synthetic gut
although i like the sound of gut the
best
this is a good solution if you don't
want to go the gut route now today we're
specifically talking about changing the
strings on a classical guitar this won't
work for steel string acoustic guitars
because they have a different system at
the bridge but actually the system that
we're going to work with today is going
to apply to flamenco guitars classical
guitars ukuleles uh all types of early
guitars loots and things um so anything
but the with a tie block bridge so step
one take off these old strings
now we don't have to be super careful
here um some people are worried about
taking off all the strings at once and
disturbing some type of tension balance
on the instrument in my experience this
doesn't make a difference and their
luthiers i've talked to seem to seem to
agree so i think it comes down to
preference my preference is actually to
do one string at a time uh and that's
just because the other strings stay in
tune and then when i put the new string
on i use the other strings to tune that
string up and then i go to the next
string and i tune it up and it just
means i don't have to use a tuner uh and
for me just makes sense in my head
whether we start with string six or one
or in the middle doesn't matter i like
to start from the biggest string and
work down to the top so this is where it
really helps to have a peg winder
because it'll save you a lot of time i
like to pluck the low e first we're
going to start with the e and then we're
going to
start turning and the reason i like to
hear the string is because i want to
make sure i don't turn the wrong
direction
like
if i kept turning the string is going to
snap off at some point and maybe i even
risk
uh ripping the bridge off so pluck the
string make sure you're turning it so it
goes all the way down you don't have to
be very gentle here
you just keep turning until eventually
the string pops out
at the bridge end
very simple just undo whatever sort of
knot is there pull the string out voila
string gone
okay let's go to our new our new pack of
strings here
open it up
actually this is just going to be a set
of bases i have
here
open up the package these aqua strings
aren't actually uh labeled
so you just have to figure out which
string is which based on the thickness
which isn't too difficult so we're just
gonna un do this little winding here and
then you'll see very clearly that one is
bigger than the rest and that's gonna be
my my low e so we're going to start on
the bridge side here and we're going to
put the string through the hole
and out the back of the instrument now
if you have a traditional bridge that
only has one hole
per string you'll have six holes um and
then it's obvious where you put it but
there are some modern instruments like
this one that have a double hole system
uh and the rule there as far as i
understand is that for the base strings
you put it on the hole closer to the
ground and for the trebles the top three
you put them on the one closer to your
your face so in this case i'm putting it
on the lower two of the holes um i pull
it through
and then i leave about i don't know
three or four inches we're going to end
up cutting the rest of this off but the
more you pull out the easier it is to to
tie around you just can't pull so much
through that you don't have enough to to
tie up top
okay so once we have three or four
inches sticking out the bridge side i'm
going to keep my other hand on the long
end of the string and actually i'm going
to take the string short end and wrap it
underneath the long end pull it taut
from here i'm going to stick the short
end through the little loop i just made
grabbing back to the long end pull it
taut
now generally i like to go around twice
uh depending on the thickness of the
string you might have to go over
a different way it's looking to me like
i need to go around one more time
okay i've gone
through the little loop twice and the
important bit is that the exit point
this excess string is going to sit on
the underside of the bridge and not on
on top of the bridge so i gave it a
little a little light yank so now it's
not going to go anywhere and we go to
the headstock side and before we do that
i just want to mention that my online
music school our pajato is now offering
a 20
discount on lessons this is our biggest
discount yet so if you're ready to start
lessons on guitar ukulele
loot or other plucked instruments just
head over to our pajato.com
now when you travel to the headstock i
like to trace the string to make sure it
didn't accidentally loop under one of
the other strings that would suck to get
it up to tension and realize you had a
knot so uh trace it to make sure that
it's not intersecting any other string
and now i have long end i like to uh
change the peg move the peg until the
the eye of the of the scroll is sticking
out in this direction so it's ready to
have a string i don't like to find the
hole with the the string so now we just
go through
pull it taut
now from here with the
the long end of the string sticking out
the back of the headstock i like to go
back
uh up through the headstock above
the scroll it just went on
keeping the tension on the string when
you do that so now i have the long end
looping through the headstock
and from here what we're going to do is
we're going to
loop this new short end underneath the
the long string
i don't think it matters which side you
go through make sure it's taut again and
now we have hooked underneath the string
and because it's wound there's all this
uh there's bumps and that's really a lot
of friction so it's not going to go
anywhere and from here i like to start
winding winding to my left
if that makes sense
i'm not sure is that that's
counterclockwise i guess
and eventually it's going to catch and
so now i can
let go and i should have some some pitch
from here save yourself a lot of time
and grab your
peg winder that's a good sound
and start winding again
pluck the string
and wind just to get a reference of
where we are pitch-wise
we don't want to go too high
so here's where i like to have the other
strings because i have my e i need an e
here
a little flat
now you could stop there but that for me
would be a waste of time because it's
going to go flat right away so let's go
a little sharp
[Music]
you can't go too sharp because you don't
want to put too much tension
but the instrument can handle
at least one semitone or two semitones
higher
okay let that just hang out
now up until recently i actually have
been pulling on my strings to give them
a pre-stretch i was taught to do that
but i was actually warned by my friend
marshall bernay who's a really fantastic
classical guitar luthier
that this can actually damage the core
of the string and make it false and i
actually have been having a problem
lately with false strings and so
he advised me not to do that so i'm
going to pass on the pre-stretch and
instead just raise the string a little
up and let it sink back down
know that it's going to go flat right
away and for for a little while that's
okay just keep bringing it back up to
pitch now at this point we have some
excess string and we have two options
option number one is just to take the
clippers
and clip the excess really close to the
knot without disturbing the knot and
without accidentally cutting the nice
string that you just
tied on that happened to me a few times
so that's option one that's very cleanly
and fine sometimes what i do for my more
expensive instruments or my my more
expensive strings i mean like if i have
gut strings which are pricey uh i like
to actually wrap the string around my my
finger
like that
to make a little loop of the string oops
that's not going so well
okay there we go and
with the excess i put the string through
the little hole
and now i have a little
a little loop here
sometimes you have to go through a
couple times
almost there we go so now i have a
little little curlicue
and if i want excess string for later
that i can pull down
this helps if you see my other video
where i show this little trick um this
also allows you to do a trick where if a
string happens to snap at the bridge
then you have all this excess string you
can pull down and just retie and in two
minutes you can save the string so your
call trim or do a little cute knot
and now we continue a string
while i'm winding the string if you're
enjoying these free guitar tips and want
to help my channel you can do so very
easily by subscribing and liking it
sharing a video and if you're really
into the channel and want to help me
make more videos you can become a patron
on patreon and get all sorts of
cool perks like behind the scenes
content
extra guitar tips just for my patrons
and a lot more so you can check those
things out
so i have two wound strings to pick from
uh that are left remember the classical
guitar has three wound strings e a d and
then three clear strings if they're
nylon uh g b e
so out of my wound strings only have two
left and i have to figure out which one
is bigger
in this case there's one clearly bigger
here and that would be my my a string so
let's learn how to tie a wound string
around the double hole system
you don't have to to use it actually it
works the same
but if you want to use the double hole
system the way it works is you go
through the the lower hole of the two
the one that's lower to the ground and
instead of wrapping underneath the long
string we're just actually going to go
around the bridge and through now the
top hole so i've made a little loop and
i'm going to go through the hole above
the one i'm on
okay and now i have a little excess
string
sticking out here and with that excess
i'm going to actually put it through the
loop
the little loop that i just made here
and now pull the long ends trapping the
little extra end on the the top side
again and
that does the same thing it just stops
the string
at the bridge i really think it doesn't
make a difference which one you use i
don't actually know why they invented
the double hole system i think it just
looks better
a common mistake that i've seen some
people do is that before they start they
actually cut the string to the length
that they think they're going to need
never pre-cut your strings
they're longer for a reason to make it
easier to tie them on so i have way more
string than i need once it's tied to the
bridge but that makes it easy to tie if
you pre-cut it and then maybe you're a
centimeter short you're out of luck
so do not cut your strings until after
it's all tied together and actually
another thing i see people do sometimes
is they they put the string through and
and
tie a little knot and they have all this
excess string sticking out they have to
coil the entire string into the scroll
and it takes forever to wind and it
takes forever to unwind so i don't
personally see the point now while i'm
winding up my my new a string i can
recheck my e's
the low e string so it's in tune and now
when i do the a
it needs to go higher than the e by a
perfect fourth
and the song for a perfect fourth is
here comes the bride so here comes the
bride it should be the a string here
comes the bride
comes the bride
and it just sounds like a perfect fourth
which is very very pure
[Music]
no beats
if you don't like here comes the bride
you can also do eyesight's baby from the
upper string
that should sound really good
again let's bring it sharp just so that
the string can settle in a little bit
now with my d string it's a thinner
string than the e or the a and i went
around twice through the loop but the
the back
the exit point of the string doesn't
seem to want to go on the back so i'm
going to loop around one more time
and now it sort of naturally falls on
the back and i just get it more taut
maybe it's worth saying just double
check that you're going to the right peg
don't forget my favorite acronym for the
string names uh eddie eight dynamite
goodbye eddie e-a-d-g-b-e
you know you're getting close
when
the string that's supposed to be higher
passes
the lower string and now we're looking
for here comes the bride the perfect
fourth
[Music]
here comes the blind here comes the
bride
there it is
now normally you'd be tying on new
troubles i'm actually repurposing some
some old nile gut troubles that i've had
in the past
just for this video so you'll see
they're a little bit worn out and
they're kind of pre-shaped but normally
they'd just be one long string
these are the nile gut strings by the
way they kind of look like a white
yellowish color as opposed to
nylon which is uh clear like plastic so
i'm looking for my g string and again
it's the thickest of the three
don't misplace the other two same deal
with the guitar in our lap with a hat
stock facing to the left of us we can go
through the bridge hole to our right
if you have only one hole it's obvious
but with the treble strings if you have
a double whole system go through the
string
closer to you for the normal method it's
the same as the bound strings we're
going to go three or four inches out of
the bridge
underneath the long end and then through
the loop we just
made enough times
to have the string exit on the back end
of the bridge often with the trebles it
takes
at least three for me
oh no i just did something that i told
you not to do
i guess this is a good learning moment
here
because this is an old string that i was
repurposing it was pre-cut
when it was already on the guitar and
that means i tied it to the bridge but
look
i didn't make it to the g so now i'm
going to have to get creative
and this children is why you don't
pre-cut your strengths
okay i'm going to use the double hole
method that i think i used last time
because it uses less string on this end
so
it goes through the same hole the string
closer to me and i'm going to go back
around and through the second hole in
this case it's closer to the ground
and then i'm gonna go
with that little tiny end through the
loop i just made trying to salvage just
mustering as much string as possible
because i'm not gonna make it
i pull it taut
okay let's see if i can do it
we have just enough
okay it's gonna work good
um
that is really annoying so that's also
another good reason to just not cut the
long end of the string on the headstock
side i find my next thickest string
there's only b and e left so b has to be
the thicker of the two as we get to the
b e strings the strings can get very
slippery and thin and so make sure you
tie enough times around if you're doing
the traditional method because if it
slips out it's going to whack the top of
the wood and put
dings and damage the top of the guitar
you can also just put a thick piece of
paper on top here to protect the guitar
now if you're a pyro and you really want
to make sure that string goes nowhere
well
we can burn the end of the string don't
let your guitar on fire
living on the edge
don't breathe in the chemicals um
now you have a little ball that's
created on the end of the string and now
it'll catch and it won't pop out on you
the first time you do this you're bound
to make some mistakes you know so
plan on spending a good half an hour to
an hour the very first time
but there's no reason you should be
bringing your guitar
into the shop to change the strings you
can if you have a guitar you can change
the strings
this is the moment where we're no longer
tuned to fourths on the guitar all the
strings are tuned to perfect fourths
except for the g to the b the third
string to the second string that's a
major third and if you want a song for
that you can do do a deer
do a deer and the deer is the b string
so do a deer
[Music]
and that should be a b
you can double check by playing ice ice
baby from the first string
so that would be too high
that'd be too low
there we go
and like i said although your first time
might take you a while
once you've done this a lot it's pretty
easy and
it takes me about 12 minutes to do the
whole thing
okay the guitar is restrong and now we
just have to clip off the excess strings
don't cut the good strings or tie them
into little curlicues if you want to
salvage the strings for later mind you
the guitar is not going to stay at this
pitch it's going to instantly
go flat and every time you pick up the
guitar it's going to need to be tuned up
again for at least a few days and then
the strings will stabilize
and now you should hear
a lot more resonance
and shimmer
in those new bass strings especially
it's hard to tune now it's coming flat
already on me
but it still sounds so good it sounds
like my guitar has come to life and i
have a brand new instrument
[Music]
so thank you so much for watching uh
please do subscribe if you haven't
already and i will see you guys next
time
[Music]
you